this facility was an old mine
it was operated for about 125 years
and these elevators are basically a mile
in depth
and now we're in the process of
converting and operating this as a deep
underground science facility really
trying to unlock the secrets of the
universe
in the middle of south dakota's black
hills lies the sanford underground
research facility
here physicists are conducting
experiments that have the potential to
alter our understanding of how the
universe was created
our lab is unique in that we are the
deepest underground facility for doing
this type of work in the united states
really the goal is to try and limit any
sort of impurities that can get into the
experiment that would cause problems
with their data collection
we're a mile underground because that
layer of rock and dirt protects us from
cosmic rays that are impinging on the
surface of the earth a number of cosmic
rays down here is effectively zero
especially compared to the surface
one of our experiments that we have in
the lab is trying to unlock questions
about particles that are fairly new in
our understanding of the universe like
neutrinos
in any given second about 60 billion of
them pass through your thumbnail
the irony is that this experiment
studies neutrinos without ever detecting
one
we are looking for a radioactive decay
that can only take place if the
neutrinos play a certain role in there
we collect about a terabyte of data a
week
you couldn't have taken this much data
let alone analyzed it 20 years ago so
it's very exciting from that point of
view
it is the team's hope that this
abandoned mine which once took from
earth will now help us understand our
place in the universe
if we understand the neutrino we can
potentially understand why the galaxies
and the stars and the planets evolved
the way they did and why they're here
we have one nobel prize under our belt
already and we're hoping that the
experiments that we have here now will
lead to additional nobel prizes in the
future
you